So now that you have a large number of tools in your regular expression tool belt.
Let's put it together and build a new regular expression.
I'd like you to submit via the interpreter.
Assign to the variable regexp, a Python regular expression that matches lowercase words--
letters (a - z) or singly-hypenated lowercase words.
Let me show you what that means.
So we could have just a word like html or a hyphenated word like well-liked.
But we don't want doubly-hyphenated words like a-b-c or 2 hypens in a row,
just these 2 options.
And it's worth noting that it may not be possible to get this perfect yet.
Not all problems are solvable. Just do your best.